DARCY LEWIS: Oh my god.
This is going on Facebook.
Smile.
[MISCHIEVOUS MUSIC]
Look at you.
Still all muscly and everything.
How's space?
Space is fine.
DARCY LEWIS: Whoa.
Does he need CPR?
Because I totally know CPR.
Is there somewhere a lady
could get a cup of coffee?
You guys look like
you might get down
with those little pod things.
Horrendous for the environment.
So I show up to work at the
lab, slash your mom's house,
fully expecting you to be
moping around in your pajamas,
eating ice cream,
and obsessing about
[CLEARS THROAT] you know who.
But you're not.
You're wearing lady clothes.
You even showered, didn't you?
You smell good.
I'll tell you everything
you wish to know.
Everything?
Yes.
All the answers you seek will
be yours once I reclaim Mjolnir.
Meow-meow?
What's Meow-meow?
Ms. Lewis.
Dr. Lewis.